[Music]
hey guys we're back in our absolute lime
green room absolute lime is the newest
citrus flavor from absolute and is the
official spirit sponsor but this
weekend's Grammy Awards it is going to
be a party and the host with the most is
James Corden of course Michelle Turner
comp with James and he'd let us in on
what we can look forward to you ready
for this chief I'm not messing around I
couldn't be more nervous oh I couldn't
get to sleep last night I was so nervous
I just but you know you have to good you
only nervous when you want to do your
best and you know I really don't want to
mess it up I don't want to let anybody
down
and there's so many people says are you
this thing at the Grammys I'm like you
know who's at the Grammys right I'm not
gonna start singing in front of Beyonce
and Adele are you karaoke you will and
you did
that's sharing in the joy two very
different in going why don't you be
quiet for a minute and listen to this
guy
the hug no one's interested in that are
you kidding me
no I've seen the look on some of those
celebrities face do you know there might
holy that's a different thing that's
because you're not the singer it seems
you fire an album
people are like who the hell else do you
think he is doing that have you
rehearsed the meeting with Beyonce like
do you come up do you shake do you go in
for the kiss do you do the weirdest
thing what are you gonna do I know
exactly what are you doing did your
feelings okay besides a good show of
your pretty no that is not a voice no
this is what I'll do I'll tell you what
everyone should you do Beyonce I won't
just
until she says I can tell my weight you
may lift you may live and then other
starts crying well I'm so excited for
you I really don't think there's
anything you can't do until Monday and
then it's all over it's been wonderful
now lose everything
cars wife's gonna divorce them what are
they gonna call him dad what a minute
wait no I never said that
what's my wife leaving me this used to
be a postive show no going through a
divorce he's the man I watched James
take the Grammy stage this Sunday on CBS